et vous allez jouer avec nous également
chez vous cet après midi il s'est passé
quelque chose de terrible et c'est vous
antoine et nadia keylemon l enquête à
une personne autour de la table a été
attaqué sauvagement elle a été attaquée
par un des chroniqueurs ici présent
d'aller tout de suite voir puisque nous
avons les images et vous avez essayé de
trouver
nadia et antoine emmenant l'enquète qui
à la personne qui a commis sur l'ars qui
al'art cynique
regardez
[Musique]
toto tu fais toi et bouge alors c'est
pas moi nada mais qui est dans la tête
des courses et des jeux qui est là alors
je vous le dis en face est l'un des
grands ne fait que toi mais c'est pas
moi l'entartage a eu lieu à 16h30
ça va les donner rapidement chacun votre
alibi et bien entendu la dernière
antoine vous essaierez trouver qui est
capable
vous étiez ou à 16h30 ici j arrive très
tôt vous devriez pas vrai il tira
pourquoi vous arrivez tôt j'arrive très
tôt parce qu'on préparez vos sont
aujourd'hui je devais m'occuper de mon
ego bébé voilà voilà
valérie benaïm vous étiez vous à 16h30
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qu à 17h45
inspecteurs je présente une émission qui
s'appelle c'est que de la télé mais il
se trouve que je suis donc dans les
locaux à vous la préparez préparer votre
mission tout à fait contrairement à ce
que vous faites sur celle ci voit bien
son affaire autre élément est bien vide
à lille et lyon gamme
je n'aime pas vos méthodes benhaim les
mots noronha être destitué donc vous
étiez six bénévoles travaillent tout à
fait vu l'émission d'aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi mais bon on peut
travailler avoir des mauvais résultats
jean michel maire je discute peu
d'entrées n'avance où l'armée pas loin
et pourquoi est ce parce que c'est mon
ami
c'est insupportable il ya des
prépaiements tu es allé taper à la porte
de france 3 seront faites de la place
vous étiez au mit csa alors vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir comme dit valérie que
tous les jours à 16h30 je suis devant
l'école de ma fille elle sera sénart
kaman a commenté vraiment je peux je
peux vous je peux appeler la directrice
achats d'eau de la paix domp et quels
moyens lourds hino tous les jours 16h30
et gilles verdez alors gb ma mère qui a
une coupure edf depuis deux jours
qu'elle en ligue avec edf pour l'afrique
j'en ai marre ça fait depuis deux jours
que ça dure
j'ai fait un tweet sur ils s'en
sortiront pas comme ça à regarder je
vais vous dire quelque chose
si c'est pas vrai j'ai envie d'y croire
vous vous étiez moi j'étais en train
d'enquêter pour vous car j'avais peur
que vous nous grandit en loge 40 cède
0,12 je vous redoutent plus que mon mari
non c'est vrai bah ça me fait plaisir
messieurs vous aimez votre mari vous
[Rires]
quelque chose qui est encore une longue
carrière devant lui
doc gynéco vous savez comment ces deux
disques vendus ça alors vous étiez où
après un déjeuner bien copieux à base de
pommes entre 14h et 17h je me lave linge
et où es tu as mangé à la pomme de pain
à mon bureau je t'ai la rédaction de
médias plus est en train de retranscrire
mes interviews de dirigeants médias si
vous travaillez beaucoup vous oui à fond
c'est fou que ça ne se voit pas du tout
bon moi j'étais chez ma grand-mère
chérie qui m'appelait en panique parce
qu'elle a une souris chez elle non oui
et donc elle était vraiment tétanisé les
lieux installer une [ __ ]
non c'est vrai est agacé jean échos
alors j'étais à l'as du falafel un alamo
jalabert d'alarmé à l'as du falafel on
m'a demandé est question je vous savez
quoi je sais que c'est pas bougé vu le
mouvement qui dure
normal
[Applaudissements]
ça serait venu au ralenti sargos lewis
et des images je pense que ça m'a donc
je sais que c'est pour je sais que c'est
pas je crois savoir qu'il serait alors
antoine duléry là où l'âge est un
enquêteur hors pair à une nadia farès
aussi à votre avis qui a comme je pense
que c'est une machination de quelqu'un
de très intelligent et que l'agresseur
est aussi d'agresser je pense que dans
la fourrure il ya également ce qu'on n'a
pas le don d'ubiquité
non c'était un montage monsieur vous
c'est de faire porter le chapeau à toute
l'équipe
j'accuse lui-même pour [ __ ] les autres
dans la mer c'est pas mal après ça je
fais partie c'est celui qui dit qu'il
est bon alors trêve de plaisanterie
c'est qu'on sait que sont antoine duléry
mais non c'est pas moi d'agir maintenant
vous dire un vrai nom alertant le
commissaire larosière pas vraiment dû
l'arrêter
je pense que c'est moi je ne suis pas
qu'on pense que c'est je pense que c'est
jean michel maire je pense quand je sais
si vous dites jean michel maire se
rassemblent dans les landes hirschel il
a tellement une tête de faux cul que
c'en est presque
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour ciseler henri jeanson tu
sais qu'ils ont une tête de faux cul que
c'en est presque de la faune nadia
déterminant c'est finalement jean n'en
passe pas un mais bien sûr at-il
formidable parce que tu es mon travail
actuel la production exactement cyril
hanouna qui s'appelle maison rouge et
qui passe ce soir et que moi
personnellement j'aime je restais sur
eux en toi tu sais sur antoine les
écouter moi je ne sais pas de qui il
s'agit ah ouais mais tu as mangé mon
idée moi pour moi bien j'hésite entre
deux personnes kelly ou maxime guillemin
car si les deux personnes qui
travaillent le moins
benjamin castaldi
malheureusement c'est fait entarté cet
après midi voilà oui on est en train de
chercher le coupable
moi j'ai hésité entre match in game et
kelly et finalement j'ai l'impression
que c'est valérie benaïm parce que j'ai
senti les modes tunisienne tu vois quand
elle est partie alors je vous le dit
antoine duléry vous avez dit vous vous
sentiez que tu es jean michel maire est
nadia farès penser que c'est antoine
duléry où vous êtes d enquêteur hors
pair à la télévision on va voir si vous
êtes d enquêteur hors pair dont la vie
mais j'ai aussi pardon hein oui après
j'ai penché vers belaïli merveille c'est
vrai j'aurai la santé benhaim et l'on
dirait que les gens sont souvent perchés
sur des gars comme il la reçoit
sans succès
elle était bonne matin casta la castagne
il est où
[Applaudissements]
un petit combat celui le dernier que je
subis ce mois ci c'est l'un des années
que sanctionner la bravo gilles verdez